miss pat is the modern day richard pryor  minus the mustache her storytelling is  all about the details couple days later  i get to school y'all and my principal  coming to me a big old tall man with  thick-ass glasses look like if he  couldn't read he could have made it to  the nba  she could have easily just said the  principal called me into his office but  adding all these extra details builds  not only punch lines but also suspense  her secret sauce here is painting the  picture with a punchline and he looked  at me and said we noticed that you got a  bunch of bruises and blisters and burns  all on you we want to know what's going  on at the house she not only paints with  words but also physicality using her  hand to physicalize her words  physical eyes  is that a word are you a carter i'm like  [ __ ] now  i was frying chicken in the chimney  this meticulous attention to detail is  exactly why